in path of Exile ascendancy you'll be
able to choose one of 19 assembled see
classes to specialize your character in
when a Templar character ascends one of
their three options as the Hierophant a
class that favors intelligent strategies
over raw power here are some of the
skills available to a Hierophant pursuit
of faith increases the hierophants
damage for each enemy he has killed
recently and increases the speed when he
has a total knowledge this can be useful
for builds that either fight with totems
or use them to support other skills
certain characters aspire to have as
many totems out as possible but these
always come at a price ritual of
awakening grants the Hierophant two
extra totems but for each active totem
they'll all do less damage illuminated
devotion adds a different bonus to
skills in the hair offense helmet gloves
or boots this has synergies with items
like rain gates that also reinforced
specific item slots conviction of power
occasionally grants power charges when
the Hierophant kills enemies and as a
chance to grant an endurance church
whenever he gains a power church this
works well with unique items that
generate large numbers of power charges
like vols protector divine guidance
provides a large amount of mana and lets
the hair offense mana absorb damage he
takes this can be used alongside the
mind of a mattock Keystone for even more
damage absorption sanctuary of thought
rewards the Hierophant with additional
energy shield based on how much money he
has this makes items that provide huge
mana boosts like pledge of hands even
more powerful
you'll be able to play your own
Hierophant and path of Exile ascendancy
which launches in march this year